[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs comme chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine jada et sorciers super héros
sont attendus ce week-end à voisins le
bretonneux
le centre alfred de vigny organise son
2e salon pop culture des classiques et
des nouveautés
jusqu'au 4 février c'est le festival
ciné junior 4 salles saint-quentinoise
projette des courts et longs métrages
destinés aux enfants dès l'âge de 2 ans
et l'agenda complet de vos sorties au
programme une exposition des coups de
coeur littéraires et du sport
les fans de la pop culture sont attendus
ce week-end à voisins le bretonneux les
25 et 26 janvier celle et alfred heroes
des et on en parle avec aurélie arnaud
bonjour vous êtes coordinatrice du
centre alfred de vigny qui organise
cette manifestation
c'est la deuxième édition parce que
celle de l'an dernier avait eu un très
beau succès cette affaire et avant le
salon était plutôt tourné vers les
warhammer vous avez choisi d'ouvrir plus
large vers la pop culture
oui tout à fait mais les autres années
c'était plutôt une journée dédiée à ce
jeu de plateau ou warhammer avec des
initiations une démonstration peinture
état et depuis l'année dernière on a
décidé d'ouvrir et de mettre à
contribution de revaloriser toute
activité association qui a un sens
autour de la pop culture sur le centre
pour montrer ce qu'ils étaient à
disposition pour la jeunesse tout au
long de la saison au centre
c'est en plus la culture pop c'est une
vraie communauté celle des gens qui se
connaissent ils se retrouvent
régulièrement alors mêlé warhammer ne
sont pas oubliés quand même ils sont
toujours là parce que vous avez même à
l'initiation au niveau des warhammer la
désignation
pour les néophytes les jeunes du club
qui se réunissent tous les samedis
après-midi organise une partie ce qu'on
me dit apocalypse qui dure deux jours
c'était grosse partie ils ont du coup on
a l'occasion de regarder d'observer
comment ils jouent quelle stratégie il
applique etc
voilà et puis on a des initiations une
vraie initiation à la peinture voire
amère donc apprentissage mais que des
couleurs simples pour leur apprendre des
basiques de la peinture sur figurines et
pour contrer dans l'univers de warhammer
il ya aussi d'autres animations qui sont
les craypion à faire un petit peu de
mots rama et on va pouvoir notamment ce
week-end à jouer à des jeux de société
ouais donc c'est une volonté c'est une
des nouveaux bénévoles qui sont venus au
centre qui aime beaucoup les jeux de
société ça s'est mis en place grâce à
nos fêtes vos yeux qu'on a à chaque
vacance scolaire et du coup on s'est dit
qu'on allait présenter des jeux de
société qui sont intéressants moins
connu du grand public et qui nécessite
une initiation pour pour ouvrir pourquoi
pas un club
cette société aux centres intéressants
de par leur thème qui se rapproche un
peu de culture parce qu'ils sont
nouveaux
intéressant parce qu'ils sortent du lot
de tous les classiques monopoly cluedo
et qu'on connaît tous et parce que ça
peut s'appliquer qu'on peut y jouer avec
de ses enfants à partir de 9 10 ans qui
peut intéresser les trentenaires et
quarantenaires etc
alors parmi les autres animations c'est
un retour celle escrime d'harry potter
ça marche toujours
ouais c'est ça un beau partenariat qu'on
a avec une association qu'elle je
travaille aussi musical event en
organise des voyages et des week-ends
immersif d'harry potter est depuis 3 4
ans et mia a créé une autre et piano
trestel game qu'on dit qu'on revalorise
du coup lors de cet événement là donc
c'est une création 100 % bénévoles aussi
avec des passionnés d'harry potter on
met à bien toute notre créativité notre
sens de logique pendant un an pour pour
créer cette escape game donc pour le
découvrir j'imagine faut peut-être
s'inscrire parce que c'est ce que vient
comme si un sac d'urée précise où il
peut pas arriver n'importe quand
des sessions d'une heure il y en a
organisé tout le samedi après midi et
toute la journée du dimanche
il vaut mieux se renseigner sur les
horaires et s'inscrire les inscriptions
ont déjà débuté depuis une semaine et
demi et sa soeur et ça ça se remplit
jamais le site s'affiche à l'écran alors
souvent les salons pop culture c'est
pour les fans et parmi ses fans et un
certain qu'ils aiment se déguiser ce
qu'on appelle le cosplay puisque vous
vous organiser un concours
oui on organise un concours cosplay donc
mes amis qui d'habitude concours à des
adieux au niveau lors du salon salon
exactement sept ont la gentillesse et là
ça les amuse aussi tout simplement de
jury et de venir à la rencontre des fans
qui sont balbutiements de construire
leur propre la propre cosplay wifi en
plus du côté des cosplayeurs c'est de la
passion des eaux tous et beaucoup de
temps en costume ça se fait pas du jour
au lendemain en faut beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de patience et c'est un vrai
art c'est l'art plastique c'est de la
couture c'est de la peinture c'est la
construction c c'est beaucoup de choses
tout une passion or dans la
programmation que j'ai vu vous faites
aussi joué la nostalgie puisque dimanche
après midi vous avez un karaoké et des
chansons bien sûr dans le thème les
pokémon capitaine flam faut s'entraîner
avant non faut venir en famille en ami
il faut pas avoir de hondo jane il faut
venir pour s'amuser pour pour passer
pour finir ce week-end sur un chanson
est bien vraiment s'amuser en groupe sur
notre karaoké pote concours peut-être
pour le meilleur chanteur la meilleure
interprétation non ça sera vraiment
l'occasion de s'amuser de de passer un
bon moment entre faire en famille on
merci aurélien non bien sûr on peut pas
tout dire il ya beaucoup de rendez vous
vite être ajouter quelque chose mais je
voudrais souligner qu'on a quand même un
bon spectacle samedi soir avec levi
signol donc on a créé pas non plus un
habitude cdma dit l'improvisation
concret le savon au centre et là c'est
tout nouveau on appelait ça un katy
d'improvisation donc il y aura une mise
en scène vraiment différente de ce qu'on
fait d'habitude avec des déguisements
des thématiques et des petites saynètes
vraiment en lien avec les super héros et
super vilains de quoi faire un bon
week-end autour de la pop culture merci
or il hier no mercy est je le rappelle
les alfred heroes les se déroule du 25
au 26 janvier ouverture des portes à 10
heures et le manga il en est question
aussi avec notre moment cinéma cette
semaine c'est gaël pinault qui vous
donnent rendez-vous on part pour le
grenier à sel connaissez-vous la
animations oui certainement vous
connaissez puisqu'il s'agit des films
d'animation japonais
donc si vous aimez les films d'animation
japonais quand on appelle aussi mon gars
ou plutôt animée nous vous proposons une
programmation spéciale le samedi 8
février à partir de 18h15
vous pourrez donc voir deux films pour 6
euros à 18h15
les enfants du temps où l'on voit deux
adolescents au daaka et ina qui font
face à un phénomène météorologique
extrême et comme l'avait fait déjà avec
excellent your name sortie fin 2016 donc
le réalisateur makoto shinkai il nous
propose une très belle histoire dans
laquelle on parle d'amour d'écologie on
rit on pleure et c'est donc ce sera le
premier film à 18h15 le deuxième film
sera millenium actress s'éteint
un film de satoshi kon c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre inédit sur grand écran
malheureusement satoshi kon nous a
quittés en 2010 et il nous a laissé pas
mal de fumer c'est exceptionnel il
aurait commencé par travailler avec
otomo sur le phénoménal akira et ensuite
il a réalisé perfect blue millenium
actress tokyo godfathers enfin pas mal
de que des bons films
les deux films ce soir là seront à 6
euros les deux films vous pouvez
réserver vos places sur notre
billetterie en ligne sur cinéma grenier
à sel point com et si vous aimez japon
nous vous donnons rendez-vous aussi le
23 février avec une programmation
spéciale
[Musique]
les plus jeunes ont aussi leur festival
de cinéma il a commencé le 22 janvier et
prendra fin le 4 février prochain le
festival ciné junior s'adresse aux plus
jeunes dès l'âge de deux ans quatre
salles de saint-quentin-en-yvelines y
participe alors on va voir on va les
voir à l'écran aux clayes-sous-bois deux
projections ce samedi 25 janvier avec
grease et les aristochats des chats que
l'on retrouve à elancourt le 26 janvier
à magny les hameaux le 29 janvier et
magny les hameaux projette aussi gâteau
de fête et compagnie et azur et asmar je
vous propose maintenant de regarder un
extrait d'une des projections rita et
crocodile est à découvrir samedi 25
janvier au cinéma elle encore ils sont
vraiment rapides et si ce qu'est ce que
tu as perdu noël
[Musique]
super retrouver un petit moment de
lecture à présent pas pour la librairie
lettres voisine ouverte depuis mai 2003
elle est tenue par christine sauvage qui
prend sa retraite
mais avant son départ elle nous fait
part de ses deux derniers coups de coeur
manon varaldo stenbeck onze mille
exemplaires sont là pour satisfaire
chaque lecteur christine sauvage la
libraire gérante nous partage son coup
de coeur le dernier livre de marc dugain
se projette dans l'avenir en 2060 dont
un peu plus et il décrit une entreprise
dont la directrice est une femme qui a
développé une intelligence artificielle
au point de créer son propre personnage
pour démontrer que ce personnage est
réelle elle est bien son double elle va
se suicider et c'est son personnage qui
va continuer à gérer et à faire une opé
a surtout les grands financiers du monde
entier qu'il nous dit quelque chose de
notre présent et notre avenir
cette libraire sort de ses livres et
voyage beaucoup elle a parcouru les
andes
je connais bien l'amérique latine j'ai
parcouru les andes du sud au nord
presque jusqu'aux normalement qu'un
petit bout descendant au en colombie je
connais bien c'est civilisation aztèque
inca istres que laurent binet renverse
l'histoire c'est à dire qu'en 492
christophe colomb n'a pas découvert
l'amérique ce sont les incas qui
envahissent l'europe et clive ont imposé
leur civilisation
christine sauvage et passionné et
continuera de transmettre le goût de la
littérature même à la retraite qu'elle
prendra le 31 janvier un concert de rock
et un concert de jazz des comptes ou
encore des marionnettes pour la deuxième
année consécutive
maurepas participent à la nuit des
conservatoires un moyen pour les élèves
de faire découvrir le fruit de leur
travail
début des festivités à 18 heures 30 ce
vendredi 24 janvier à l'espace albert
camus est un peu de sport ce week-end le
club ckw d'un dragon noir organise un
championnat d'île de france au programme
du bouchon
au lieu du kung fu traditionnelle et du
taï ji quan rendez vous au gymnase des
droits de l'homme de guyancourt et comme
chaque semaine on termine ce cette ut
loisirs avec un sujet de nos confrères
de via grand paris on part pour le
centquatre le site parisien vous
entraîne dans un monde où l'homme a été
vaincu par les machines regarder
bienvenue en 2020 l'humanité a disparu
mais les machines lui ont survécu
robot intelligence artificielle et
organismes modifiés règne désormais sur
le monde dans ce musée du futur 30
artistes ont collaboré pour imaginer ce
que seraient les vestiges archéologiques
de notre époque
des oeuvres qui pointe les travers de
notre société et notre dépendance à la
technologie aux s'adresse alors aux
spectateurs comme à des postes humains à
des êtres du futur qui arrive au
centquatre et qui découvre finalement
les ruines archéologiques de l'espèce
humaine pour mais les spectateurs dans
cette position qui comme m interroge des
futurs pas reluisant puisque bon a
priori la disparition de l'espèce
humaine ça fait pas rêver et on la
présente comme un futur possible pour
l'homme s'il ne fait pas attention à son
rapport aux technologies installations
atypique archéologie post apocalyptique
et création robotique tous les supports
sont utilisés pour projeter le visiteur
dans des univers futuristes inquiétants
mais pas question de sombrer dans le
catastrophisme si certains artistes
jouent à nous faire peur d'autres
cherchent à nous interpeller grâce aux
sarcasmes et à l'humour comme avec cette
techno fossiles d'internet où cette
assistance respiratoire qui jouent de
leurs yeux
c'est une exposition qui peut avoir une
apparence un petit peu noir comme ça
dans ce côté dystopie mais en fait c'est
pas du tout comme ça que les spectateurs
la ressentent je pense que c'est un vrai
bonheur pour les pour les visiteurs on a
beau leur raconter que l'espèce humaine
était une créature un parfaite dans le
rôle principal a été de permettre
l'émergence des machines c'est quand
même pas tout à fait comme ça qu'ils
perçoivent les choses et on sent une
réaction quand même on sent que non on
est là et on est bien là et on a compris
que le numérique on doit le dominer et
la technologie
eh ben elle devient ce qu'on fait en
fait une exposition accessible à tous et
surtout ludique
vous avez jusqu'au 9 février prochain
pour vous rendre 104 et découvrir à quoi
pourrait ressembler le monde sans vous
c'est la fin du statut de loisirs merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve jeudi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
oui
ouais
[Musique]